it was only a meth lab if it had porn
indian artifacts and a dream catcher
hanging on the wall a blue funnel a blue
funnel
[Music]
hey sean what's up howard man i tell you
what's up heat this summer is full force
it is brutal well i i mean i know you've
been on the golf links playing a little
bit huh i have conditioning myself how's
your game coming it is it's coming all
right man um still relatively new to the
sport or actually i am new and i don't
know if i actually caught a sport but
i'm new to golf
a little less than two years now and
my goal this year is to not go over
break into the triple digits anymore so
stay 19 90s and below and then hopefully
next year it's all in the 80s so
actually played today and shot an 88 so
so far so good i know you hit up with
the golf like i'm hit up with a mountain
bike that's correct hey but we got a
good guess for us today actually this
guest is from
maybe you don't know this my little
standing joke is when people ask me
where i'm from
where do i say
or kansas yeah l.a
lower arkansas well speaking of mountain
bike this dude looks like a mountain man
he does man he is he's got a voice
deeper than both of us but together yes
absolutely like i we were kind of joking
with him before we went on air just
sounds like puberty kicked in recently
and his voice dropped and he's got you
know
facial hair and probably hair and other
parts of his body girls give him a funny
feeling now things like that yeah that
funny feeling that's wonderful i
actually shaved this morning
[Laughter]
this gentleman's from my neck of the
woods where my dad's family from around
monticello arkansas we have lots of
police officers on here that are from
big areas like la and new york and
those big jurisdictions and
we've got somebody here who has a little
bit more i guess we could call rural is
oh yeah the best way to put that yeah
well before we before you actually even
introduce the guest by his name
just last night i was looking at
something that was put out i don't know
if it was one of the news agencies or
something but it was talking about the
10 states
in the u.s where people shower the least
and i'm just going to put this out there
i'm going to just say it
oklahoma was not on that list
arkansas was and i'm not that serious it
was it was on that list
so just saying that just saying that
fake news man take it for what it is
that's just fake news take it for what
it is didn't have it like hey who else
was on the list i wanted mississippi
kentucky uh new york i think west
virginia was number one if i remember
correctly but uh it was a lot of
southern states we just don't like the
baths i i guess i don't know it's
natural to smell good there you go
well we got brett reeves on today he is
a uh he's going to be our guest he's
from he he actually lives in cabot now
cabin arkansas are you familiar with
cabinets i am not familiar with cabot
arkansas i don't know if anybody
listening is familiar with cabot arc
it's right out cabot um is right outside
of a big big big city in arkansas called
little rock oh i am aware of little rock
yeah so little rock's the capital of
arkansas man you are good at geography i
did pay attention most of the time in
school you i thought the only place you
knew in arkansas was fayetteville
i know of fayetteville i know what uh
siloam springs siloam springs yeah
that's another one yeah so doing well so
far does happen to be about an hour away
from us that's the only reason that's
yeah all right mr reeves welcome to our
show
oh thank you
well we always have a drink on this uh
podcast
our guests don't always have a drink but
we always have a drink and we let you
choose the drink this time and we told
you you couldn't choose apple crown
because yeah
that's awesome because you have a beard
that's you yeah exactly drink it you're
not allowed to drink it probably stand
with a pee also yeah absolutely not like
quincy yep if i can
all right so what did you pick for us to
drink this evening
oh
i was gifted uh
last christmas some uh
suburban that's actually made north of
the mason dixon line up in chicago
and it's called it's a kova l however
that's properly pronounced
but it is uh it's pretty sporty that's
it right there
coval covale however you want to say it
but it's uh it's good whiskey and
it'll make your truck drive funny before
you know if you ain't careful
well we're going to be the judge of
whether this is good whiskey we had a
bottle and it was pretty emptied so
shawn and i have very discerning pallets
when it comes to bourbon so hot well
yeah hot spicy
orange
here's the use of our cheers oh yeah
thanks guys thanks for having me all
right
his poor's a little bigger than ours
legally he drinking iced tea
you know
what you think sean it's actually not
bad it is it's got a little syrupy
flavor to it yep ah yeah it'd probably
be good on pancakes it would be i
actually have some pappy's syrup i know
they make that yeah i actually have some
my mom got it for me for like christmas
a year or two ago i've never tried it
yet like a lot of my bourbon
well shawn a little known fact about
sean chan is a um he's kind of a good
cook he's really good at cooking
breakfast breakfast that's my go-to but
he's like a firefighter when it comes to
cooking breakfast he only can cook like
four or five loaves of french toast at a
time so i mean if you ever have if you
ever have over the shines you gotta eat
like nine pieces of french toast for
breakfast that's a little known fact
there
that's how you end up over six feet tall
that's right you eat breakfast
you eat biscuits at my house and that's
that's how you get six foot wide
all right sir
tell us how you got into law enforcement
well i tell you i don't come i have uh
my brother my oldest brother worked for
the state police uh not long after he
got out of high school as a
dispatcher and radio operator i had a
first cousin who was a trooper and
a lot of military folks in our
background my family i served in the
military
and it was just more or less
something that i knew at
a young age
i had decided between
when i grew up i either wanted to be a
stunt man or a policeman so i became a
narcotics cop and i kind of did both so
it was kind of a kind of an easy
easy
career path to follow
and
it's been 31 years now working on
working on 32 years now
so you're on the back side of your
career
i hope so i hope i'm getting close to
the end of it it's uh i could actually
retired last year but i've got a got a
good job now where i'm at there's not a
lot of stress not a
all the door kicking days are behind me
now and
it's uh
it's a good way to
to ride it out right off into the sunset
yeah for sure i mean that that type of
stuff i guess the the exciting part the
fun you know that as you said the door
kicking those type of things that's the
young man's job i mean it is don't get
me wrong there's guys that do it long
into their career
but
that's kind of the goal if you're going
to be a 30-year cop a 35-year guy man
the last side you know you've put your
time in you busted your ass you try to
find that spot that you can
uh you know kind of kick back
still be productive but the department
kind of rewards you with a with a nice
little spot to ride out towards
retirement yeah i know exactly
exactly i was talking
when i got into this position it's
almost eight years ago now
uh i was in it a couple of years and you
know you're used to that
just slamming banging all the time
stress and and adrenaline and you're
just just going full speed all the time
and when it slow it went from 100 miles
an hour to 10 miles an hour it was a
pretty hard adjustment for me for a
while and
i kind of got the blues man kind of
kicked my whole lip around and i thought
you know
i've had all this training of all all
this experience and
you know kind of wasting it in this
position and and my oldest daughter who
who missed a lot of
me growing up when she was growing up
because i was off doing these things
she said daddy you know you've
you've
you've done your part
and you're relatively healthy from it
and you know you just chill it's all
good let somebody else do it
and it was a it was a pretty sobering
conversation we had with a
i had with a 20-something year old
daughter he was actually seeing things
for you know the way it was so
it helped a lot
so yeah gotta get things in perspective
well yeah i mean you got to think of all
the stress that your family probably had
you doing all that running a gun and
stuff i mean they take that's that's
kind of hard on the kids it's kind of
hard on the wife it's kind of hard on
people that love you
yeah well yeah
yeah i mean you know if you're working
narcotics or anything like that i mean
it is yeah you're going to have a sit
set schedule on paper
um but you know in the job we call it
doper's time i mean everything evolves
around the dope world and what they're
doing and you know i mean uh i mean
brent you know there's a you know you've
got an informant who goes hey i'm
meeting this guy at three in the
afternoon and we're gonna buy
you know a quarter ounce or whatever it
is and
it's 7 30 at night and you know we're
still trying to do the deal and next
thing you know it's 9 30 at night you're
still trying to do the deal and you're
supposed to have gotten off work at five
i mean that's just how it is and then
yeah you know you type you're gonna type
a paper for a search one we're hitting
him at six o'clock tomorrow morning and
then
it's just how it goes um so there's a
lot of time spent away from home in
those narcotics deals and
you know even if you've got
saturday sunday off or sunday night or
whatever the day's off you know some
doper calls you and goes hey man there's
a load coming in on saturday at two in
the afternoon guess who's coming in
saturday at two o'clock to work right
yeah yeah birthday party or not you
gotta go that's it that's it you know
just talking about your daughter
talking to you about the you know
finding this other type of position um
i mean brent obviously we've never met
each other but i i was i just retired i
was a cop for 25 years here in tulsa
did narcotics and all that stuff at
different points throughout my career
but i was speaking at an event uh
not too long ago up in baltimore for a
bunch of police officers
and before i uh
got up there and spoke i did my research
on kind of what i was going to talk to
everybody about and it was just about
the stress of the job right now
especially you know post george floyd
and the the anti-police rhetoric that's
out there and things like that how much
tougher it is for us and stressful but
one of the things i found there was a
study uh done a few years ago and it
talked about the average
male
uh you know with a career in law
enforcement compared to a male in the
civilian world
our life expectancy for cops career cops
is 22 years less than somebody in the
civilian world
and you know i mean that's that's really
a difference between
you know us seeing you know a kid
getting married a grandkid being born
things like that
and it's just tough it's so whole point
of that is it's good at that latter part
of your career to hey i've done
everything i'm gonna kind of go on
cruise control now and extend uh extend
your career and your hopefully a healthy
life
yeah i hope so you know it was uh
for a long time um
my whole identity was
was not having an identity more or less
and you know and being
working narcotics and stuff and that was
like you talked about earlier you know
everything gets put on the shelf the job
comes first
and you're missing these things is
missing these events in your life and
and
that you know that only goes so far and
just
it leaves a big empty hole where you
know family should be and
now that i'm on the
correct side of it it's a it's a whole
lot easier to lay down and go to sleep
at night and knowing that if the phone
rings in the middle of the night my it's
because my coon dog got out i'm not
fixing it right
that happens all the time
enough doesn't have to get up and be
gone for a week you know right right
well you know one of the tough things
about it is is we
in this job especially if you're good at
the job
uh you know at your your
your good undercover type of deal you
think man i have to be the guy that does
this and it's not an ego thing it's just
like man i'm good i want this to be done
you know i don't think the next guy can
do it as well as what i'm gonna do and
again it's not for the glory of hey i
got this bust it's just
you know you're invested in it and we
see it time and time again as we get
older other people that retire whether
it's a homicide sergeant that retires
like god lee there's nobody that's going
to be able to replace that guy well
guess what that position is going to get
filled and there's going to be somebody
that steps in and does the job
and you know we have to accept that just
knowing hey there's someone behind us
that's going to step up and do the exact
same thing we're doing just as good
oh yeah yeah and it's just hard when
you're in that when you're in that
position you know it was it was
it was actually what transitioned to me
from patrol to narcotics when when i
went from from wearing a uniform to
looking like i looked now
it was it was hard for me to see you
know you work radar and you work speed
enforcement to prevent accidents but you
you you assume that you do prevent
accidents but you don't you don't really
know but if i lay my hands on two kilos
of cocaine that that i'm going that once
it gets adjudicated it's going to be
destroyed i know that two kilos did not
get out on the street and it was the
difference in
reactive law enforcement i guess and and
proactive that
what led me into that to begin with so
it was
i don't know if i guess more of a
feeling of um
not accomplishment uh maybe that is
maybe it is a feeling of accomplishment
knowing that i mean that you got that
you actually did something
viable that you could actually lay your
hands on and say you know i know that
that stuff right there is not going
or it doesn't need to go
well you were you alluded to being a
state trooper
and well i've always had no no he never
said that yeah that was my that was my
brother worked for the state police yeah
i was a a deputy deputy okay
well can
uh how did you get into that deputy role
and where was that role and what kind of
jurisdiction did you have and how many
people were you overseeing in that role
there's a lot of questions well
i went to i went to work for the bradley
county sheriff's office in warren
arkansas
that was the home where where i went to
high school where i grew up
in my home in warren arkansas
at that time i probably had a population
of about 7 000 people
um
county-wide there was probably
15 000 people
at the most probably closer to 12
and there was three of us there was a
sheriff and three deputies and
deputies were
usually on
uh you know by themselves so your backup
was
uh ten minutes away and and jesus and
that was you know you pretty well on
your own
so
you learn pretty quick
when you're
15 miles from
town
in the middle of nowhere and there's
there's folks that are
you know duking it out that
you're going to have to handle
situations a lot differently than you
would if you know you roll up with a
fire team full of folks that
can start issuing out you know
black eyes to folks if they're not doing
what you want to you i think it makes
you a little more of a
a mediator
instead of
you know strong-arming so
it was uh you learn pretty quick
you know that you got that your your
verbal skills are probably going to save
you quicker than your than your fist
will
well you so this county had
12 000 people in it right and yeah
i'm guessing
i'm from this area right how do you go
undercover when 6 000 of those people
are your relatives
well when i went undercover
i was running i was in charge of the
drug task force i left
the sheriff's office
and i
uh was appointed
by um the prosecuting attorney as the
head agent for the drug task force
in the 10th judicial district which
encompassed all of southeast arkansas
and i think it was like five or six
counties and then i had
four agents working for me
and we all
being a supervisory agent
i also had you know made cases myself so
there was five of us working in six
counties and
you know spread spread pretty thin
but that's that's how i did it i worked
i never worked undercover in any place
that you know i had footprints in
growing up
in this part of the state
and brent this little this task force
i'm assuming it's kind of one of these
that's uh
made up of other whether it's deputies
or municipal officers or a state officer
or something like that from the area
from those six counties are talking
about
yeah it was they were all full-time
positions except for one we had uh
because most of the you know most of
those small departments down there if
they've got a guy on the payroll they
need him you know they can't spare a guy
right to go to be a full-time assign
somewhere else when when they need him
for patrol there in their municipality
or their county
so they were all state mandated
positions except for one and monticello
police department
and uh where you're talking about howard
um your folks are from they they donated
a man who was actually
that guy is one of the my closest
friends ever he is the chief of police
there now and
hopefully fixing to be their mayor down
there soon so
did he show up in a bow evil t-shirt
he's actually from hamburg so i was
actually surprised he had shoes on when
he got there
my grandmother lived in hamburg
actually actually a little place called
milo around there milo
i know i i know of all these places so
yeah
during your time on the drug task force
what'd you get into
oh man i tell you that was would have
been the uh the early 2000s and
methamphetamine was was a hot ticket you
know everybody was a meth cook and let's
say you want those one pots everywhere
oh yeah yeah man and it was uh we were
averaging at one time you know about
three labs a week
and
for a short stint and
for a long period you know a year so we
were doing three or four a month and it
was just
it's the craziest thing i ever was ever
involved in
there was uh
everybody was a cook everybody you know
the internet was new you could get
everything off the internet
everything you needed you could go to
walmart and you could buy everything you
needed to cook meth in walmart and
before you before you had to sign for
sinus medicine and
and all of that it was just it was wild
man it was absolutely buck wild down
there well how did you how did you find
those so this area that
for our listeners out there this area is
a bunch of uh
if you've ever used paper in your life
it's probably come from this area there
are pine trees everywhere it's
georgia pacific is the big place down
there if you haven't had the uh
the privilege of smelling a paper mill
you haven't lived you know or a meth lab
oh a paper mill makes a meth lab smell
delicious and i don't even know what a
meth lab smells like
but there there are few there are a few
people and many trees out there how in
the hell did you find these meth labs
man it's just like you find anything
else you know loose lips sink ships and
uh
folks get to talking and they get to uh
you know we we ran a a big uh
circuit of in informants you know we got
a lot of the local municipalities helped
us man because
you know they're stopping folks on
traffic stops and you know they get you
know a pocket full of weed and then
folks know that they'll they'll trade
weed for meth any day you know so they
just work it at the chain and we'll get
a call from a deputy saying hey we got a
guy stop down here
and he's got some he's going to jail or
he's going to talk one of the other so
you know it's like you talked to early
ryan about you know getting up and going
on saturday when you were you're fixing
to take the kids on a pony ride you
gotta load up and
and roll out and talk to some yahoo down
on the side of the highway somewhere
that that wants to trade information for
jail time and he was talking about
smelling uh smelling a meth lab it
reminded me of a deal a little story i
can tell you if you if you want to hear
one absolutely
we we were invited
up into a county that we didn't normally
work but they um the task force that
worked that area up there was just
absolutely over loaded with with work
and this sheriff was on the he was on
the edge of the account he's actually
boarded our district and he called me
and
and the task force folks called me too
and said hey man if you can help this
guy out help we absolutely don't have
anybody to spare
so the sheriff calls it and says look
i've got some reliable information these
folks are going to make a big cook it's
going to be at this location it's going
to be within the next two days next
three days
i think he said
and
it was actually a perfect storm we we
had just finished a couple big cases up
we didn't have anything going
and so we jumped on it so it was all of
us and two state agents went up there
and we laid on this place uh for
about a day and a half waiting on the
they built us some hides out in the
woods and they were supposed to come to
this gravel pit
and do their cook and after
like hour
36 or whatever when everybody there
would have made the didn't take a shower
list ryan we uh they finally they
finally show up on doper time like you
called it
so they roll up in there and they
they've got the components and we jump
them and we get them all arrested and
everything
we've got all the stuff spread out there
on the tailgate of the truck and
the sheriff that called us he he shows
up we call him to come in and look at it
we're waking we're waiting on
the lab disposal folks to come out of
little rock to come get all this stuff
and
the sheriff was up there and we're
showing him all right now sheriff here's
here's where they strip the lithium out
of the batteries these are the strips
right here here's where they had the
the ephedrine right here the
pseudoephedrine that they're they've got
it in this soak and in this container
right here
is one of those if you remember those
little workmate drink uh
igloos like the carry water in it's got
a
like a big thermos top on it i said now
in this
container right here is anhydrous
ammonia
somebody said something and i turn
around and to talk to them when i turn
back the sheriff's got the lid unscrewed
off
and i'm saying sheriff don't and about
the time he stuck his nose over there
and took right over
and
he passed smooth out hit the gup
he
hit the ground of course we had an
ambulance on standby so they come in
there and they're
they're getting the sheriff coming back
to and which i mean it could have been
bad but it wasn't it didn't it just
he just overcame and he passed out but
when he woke up the first thing he said
when his eyes opened up was who kicked
me
he thought somebody kicked him
because surely he wouldn't do something
so dumb like that yeah so
but he uh when he come to him we told
him what happened he's like you know
y'all don't say anything about that yeah
yeah i got an election coming up so and
now your podcast telling all about it
yeah i didn't say what county it was so
hey don't they steal that stuff from uh
like fertilizer that uh
yeah
yeah yeah
i mean
like one of those
like he was saying back in the one pod
days i mean when they changed the the
pseudo-veteran laws it made it i mean we
don't even find one pots at all anymore
not to uh by i mean we really don't but
i'll tell you this you know here in
tulsa i just texted a guy that
by the name of mike griffin from our
narcotics unit who was kind of like our
meth lab guru
but i asked him you know what was the
most we had in 2011 we had just under
500
meth lab call outs here and that's
callouts that's not total so you would
show up someplace where whether it's a
disposal i mean i'm i'm not exaggerating
there might be 30 or 40 one pots which
are typically you know two liters
that have been all dumped somewhere and
we have to go clean it up yeah i mean it
was so bad for you know here in tulsa or
you know arkansas and a lot of other
parts of the country but at the time i
was in the gang unit and gang units
guess what gangsters don't they don't
mess around with meth labs that's not a
that's not a meth lab world
but we had so many of them that our
narcotics unit our day shift and our
evening shift and even our vice unit
they were overworked because it's all
they were doing that all of us in the
gang unit we had to go to meth lab
school to dea school and
uh just to you know understand the whole
process of it and how to clean them up
so about every i think it was every five
weeks six weeks you know we're the
various units at our division
we rotated through who was on meth lab
duty that week as we called it
and the week that you were on you knew
you were not doing any other type of
investigation we weren't investigating
shootings we weren't out on the street
stopping gangsters you were just mopping
that's all you do that whole week you
were doing nothing but math labs and it
is and just you know as he was talking
about i mean it's the lithium amount of
lithium batteries pseudo federum you
know the little um
cold packs you buy for you that you toss
into you know that the medical cold
packs you pick up at walgreens yeah they
cut those open i mean you know it's a
it's a it's a bunch of damn poison it's
a and that's what baffles me like in
i'm sure people will take this wrong and
i don't intend it to sound wrong like i
understand
people that smoke weed i understand
someone's like you know what i'm going
to try cocaine i mean obviously it's
illegal i understand
but
meth you know meth or heroin i mean it's
like there's so much information out
there of how fucked up these are and the
chemicals that are in it and so forth i
just don't understand people trying it
because it is
it's so bad
yeah that's bad news man it
i've seen and you see some of the i've
seen some of the
really good people that get on that
stuff and whether they get on it for
a lot of folks that we got or i had
dealings with
you know said they they got on it to you
know to lose weight yeah help them study
stay up late work you know whatever um
drive trucks
yeah you know we we'd run a search
warrant we had uh assisted u.s marshals
on a felony warrant one time
on a guy that was just trafficking uh he
was actually if there's a marijuana
trafficking case and
marshalls were serving the warrant and
we located him he was living he was i
was in bradley county he's living in the
middle of the woods so
we slip up out there and we're going
they want to hit him you know like at 3
o'clock in the morning when he's getting
asleep
and
my agents and now we we trained for you
know
entry and search warrant stuff so
we're going to be the approach team slip
up there and secure the house and then
the marshals would come up there and
kick the door and as we slip up there
and it's three o'clock in the morning
this guy's out in his garage painting
his car with a paintbrush
oh
so just because he you know he's run out
of stuff to do so he's oh yeah the
number of yards that got cut in the
middle of the night
the engines that were taken apart and
clean for no reason hey let me ask you
this brent
how much porn did you find on search
warrants around meth labs it was only a
meth lab if it had porn
indian artifacts and a dream catcher
hanging on the wall a blue funnel a blue
funnel a blue funnel yeah and yeah i
mean and literally this is you know it's
funny to say but i cannot tell you how
much porn you would find on these and
sex toys i'm talking yeah and just so
we're talking these guys you know men
and women whatever they are they
they're awake for hours or days on end
and they are so fidgety and
you find like 300 cell phone chargers
they're cell phones that are taken apart
and all in a drawer together but guys
that literally work on sex toys like you
would find a whole drawer of them
they're taking them apart and i'm dead
ass serious i'm gonna figure out how
this works that thanks spinning on the
end yep he uh you know i had a guy that
turned out to be an informant for me and
uh is doing really good in life now but
he when the first time
that we arrested him he said you know
there was one time about a month ago he
said i knew y'all
had those listening devices in my house
and he said he said i took all the
paneling out of the house and then i
tore all the sheetrock out he said and i
could never find him he said i'm i'm
curious if you tell me what they were of
course we didn't have anything in his
house of course yeah paranoid and he
said i said well i can't tell you what
that what those things are you know he
said well i understand he said he said
but one thing something else that really
bothered me he said when y'all were
laying out there in the backyard and i
was shooting at y'all he said oh shit he
said i didn't get close to anybody did i
and i said no you did and i said you're
good buddy i said you did we shoot back
he's like no i said well we probably
wasn't there
yeah no no i know you were there i know
you were there
you're like buddy you're still alive
here talking to us
we were not out there yeah we weren't
there yeah brian that's another thing is
i always said it man the tweakers you
know back in the day man just incidents
like that you're talking about
they were the dudes that scare me i like
seriously gangsters you know guys are
doing robbery robberies and shooting one
another and typically responsible for
the homicides here in tulsa those guys
don't scare me yeah but it was guys that
were on dope because they were
completely unpredictable absolutely they
didn't have a clue and you didn't have a
clue what they were doing but they
didn't have a clue what they were going
to do yep i mean just from one minute to
the next and
and those guys i've seen them be up for
we have we had a guy this this guy in
particular on that case when he was
telling me that that information that
dude was up like three days i don't know
how long he'd been up before we got a
hold of him and got him in a
you know in an undercover apartment that
we had to try to dry him out but he was
he was up for three days
you know after we got him before we
could finally lay down and
and go to sleep so i mean
i don't i don't see houses folks
how they do it how they last long and a
lot of them don't you know but that guy
thankfully that guy thankfully got his
life squared away and
his uh he and another one have actually
been
did well and i it was it was worth going
all through it to get those folks
squared away so absolutely yeah so just
uh uh
you know obviously the people that watch
this on youtube or here on the channel
you get to see your handsome face and
for those that are listening on other
platforms he's got more grannies beard
than i do he's dude we got we're rocking
a nice little gray beer we've got some
glasses similar to howard's it's
something's like howard and looking at
himself in a mirror here we're probably
a can yeah
could be it is arkansas you know eskimo
brothers that's it
right maybe
um
he's rocking some coveralls you come
overalls or coveralls what do you call
them yeah here in america we call these
uh overalls overalls okay overalls yeah
a little and this great t-shirt so
you've done undercover work yourself
um kind of you know like as you talked
about kind of the back end of your
career now so
man what's some of the stuff you've
gotten involved with
uh you know you yourself doing
undercover because that's a lost art
there's a most cops just manage
informants they themselves don't do much
undercover work
yeah
and i did you know i did i did that too
uh one of the uh
there's when i was imagining the foreman
i'll tell you a story about this and
then i'll tell you one about one that i
did myself
but it was
it it applies to
why people sell dope they you know they
get addicted and in the dope game
they're either addicted to the dope or
they're addicted to the money
but both of them will always
you know eventually bite you in the hind
end before it's over with and we had a
guy that we were um
had targeted
and was trying to run informants on
there and trying to run information on
him and just couldn't ever get in there
we couldn't get anybody to introduce one
of us to get to him
and finally man we got we had a guy that
had been an informant
before i even started to work as a
police officer this guy had been a
snitch for a long time
and he occasionally could be able to buy
from this guy so we we wired him up and
sent him up there and he goes up knocks
on the door and the target comes to the
door which was
you know a freak accident normally it's
one of his minions that comes to the
door
and he comes to the door and and he says
he talks to the informant calls him by
name
he says uh
i know you're working for the police
and the informant pulls 100 bill out of
his pocket and then the next breath he
says
but i see you got that money in your
hand so i'm going to excel to you
so his uh his his addiction obviously
was to the money
yeah and
of course he wound up going to prison
over it but i it was it never
there was a steady stream of traffic in
and out there it was like this guy was
losing money but he could not let a
hundred dollars walk away and was going
to risk knowing that guy had been an
informant in the past
he just had to risk it to get that
to get that hundred dollars but
yeah one of my favorites for that guy
oh that guy he's man we had so many
cases on him he
he took a plea for like 30 years yeah
he was going to get the hammer
did he end up going to cummins
uh yeah i'm sure he did
they usually everybody goes there at
some point they call that gladiator
school over there now that's where the
uh
a lot of the young offenders go and
it's a
you know pretty well free-for-all over
there
but another another guy this i worked
this guy hand-to-hand and he had come up
in the
information and i was uh down in el
dorado i was living in el dorado at that
time
which is on the border of arkansas in
louisiana
and this guy
we knew who he was but didn't have a
name for him
and he was moving
meth everywhere and just
everywhere they always come up with this
this crazy name for this guy you know
and i can't remember what the nickname
was but
you know oh bingo over here he's you
know he's the guy he's the man he's the
one that's selling the good stuff and i
finally finally found somebody to
introduce me to him
and after about the third meeting he
agreed to sell me some but he's still
not giving me his name
and this goes on i started having a
weekly meeting with him and i'm i'm
spending 100
200
500
700 you know and i'm i'm buying some
weight off of him
and he's still not telling me his name
and
i'm driving my my undercover truck is as
an old work truck and it's got tools and
stuff all in the back of it and i roll
up there one day and
this guy's name he or he he meets me and
he goes uh man what kind of work you do
i never never asked you what kind of
work you do i said well i run a
construction job
i said we're working out here west town
there was a there was a job going west
of town out there and i said i'm working
doing some subcontracting out here
with this uh tree planting stuff he said
you ever need welders i thought that's a
crazy question why would you ask me that
and i said yeah i can use a welder you
know somebody needs a job he said man i
do i wailed he said i can weld a nat's
ass to a windowpane
i said really
he said yeah i said man we're short of
welder right now i said i bring you
application are you interested in going
to work he said i'd love to so i said
look i'll be back next thursday
regular time i'll bring it with me meet
you right here i want i want my standard
order and i'll bring you the application
he's like fire man fire
so i'll go back to the office and type
up an application and microsoft word is
such a beauty
yeah i meet him back the next week and
i hand him a pen he fills out everything
i need for the search warrant
social security number name address a
whole ball of wax
hey buddy part of this hardest
application process we just need a
picture and i need your fingerprints so
we know what you want hey yeah yeah do
you mind taking a pizza
so we go back man that was that's one of
the funniest things they ever did uh
easiest case to handle huh yeah you know
we the prosecutor was just chomping on
us y'all got to find out who this clown
is you got to find out who he is and he
was just he's just one step ahead but
we got him finally well sean this would
be one that you would say um
you need to find something else to do
you ain't very good yeah you're not very
good at this yeah you're not
you're not a good dope dealer man you
need to find a new job yeah that was all
that was always fun like i'd always ask
him what you want to be when you grew up
yeah oh i wanted to be a cowboy well you
should have stuck with that because you
ain't got it you're not very good at
this not a very good criminal
you know just to uh again throw a story
out there the year that i was in
narcotics um i was a supervisor of the
unit so i didn't do any undercover work
i tried to grow a beard i did not look
like either one of you two i was funny
with a beard i looked like a cop with a
beard i mean that's what i look like
it's like everyone looked at hey that's
a cop growing a beard you know it was
pretty obvious but
um we had a couple guys in my unit and
still undercover stuff they do to this
day so i'm not gonna name them but
uh we had these hispanic bars that were
selling a lot of cocaine out of and it
was pretty much literally just hispanics
that were in there so you know if you're
a white guy and you walk in it's like
you know the scene out of a movie where
the music just goes
and everybody's looking over you know
they look the part though both of these
guys did both of them country boys from
you know out here in oklahoma uh best
narcotic cops i've ever worked around
one of them now
is uh he is actually used by federal
agencies across the country he has flown
around to do undercover stings now
because he is that good at it and he's
been all these federal schools for
undercover
and just like i was saying earlier man
it's it's a lost art for cops to do
undercover work oh yeah but the
construction thing was exactly what uh
this guy was doing and that's what he
said he he said he was running a
construction crew up in kansas and
that's why he kept increasing the size
of his orders he kept buying from these
guys because he was you know he had
family in tulsa he had a girl here in
tulsa is what he would say so he was
popping into this bar just kept buying
bigger and bigger dope that he was
taking back to sell to uh
sell to the guys that were working the
construction site up in kansas and again
it's that money man even though they
know to be leery of these guys it
shouldn't be in there
yeah it just kept building and building
it and i mean it was the bartenders that
were selling it you know that were part
of it the people behind the uh or that
you know that were that were just there
daily they were selling it and so forth
and
ended up being a fantastic case we hit a
whole bunch of hispanic bars closed them
down
um but one of the funny things was one
of the two guys that worked undercover
uh one of the girls working in the bar
developed uh an interest in him like she
really liked him and it was and she
would i wish i could say his name
because it's the way she would say it
was so funny amongst us make the name
howard i say it the way she says
you know something like that but but uh
you know the the boots would call them
the cockroach killers the the cowboy the
hispanic cowboy boots that have the long
pointy like
boots
literally when they you know when they
get dressed up man the you know these
gangsters or these ha the cartel-esque
type guys they do man it's the belt
buckle that matches the hat the whole
thing they're cowboys
and she brought him some cowboy boots
like that
after this investigation went on for
like six plus months and so he would he
would rock these things around man oh my
god it was so funny
he's got red hair he's like this
red-haired guy with a red beard and he
would rock his boots
oh my gosh it was so funny
that's hilarious
hey well time has flown we're almost to
the end you want to uh kind of close us
out tell us what you're doing now note
you have a hat on called bear grease
yeah i'm uh i i help with a a podcast
it's a meat-eater podcast
a good friend of mine and he's just like
a brother clay newcomb does this
podcast it's a documentary style podcast
every other week and then
the off weeks
me and a couple other folks including uh
clay clay's wife misty usually and his
dad and a couple other guys
we'll uh we'll get together and we'll
discuss
what the topics were you know what we
got out of the
of the of the podcast the week before so
it's um
very popular man it's just growing like
like a weed and clay does an outstanding
job with the with it it's very
interesting it could be it's not just
you know hunting and fishing we did or i
say he did one uh had a lot of
interesting topics that maybe about
daniel boone about arrowheads
actually did one uh just got through
with a three-part series about some
about some old hometown turkey poachers
down where down where he grew up in
southwest arkansas and uh
it was really interesting man these
folks where i mean were absolute turkey
serial killers but they were well
regarded and would you say that again
please just say that we've never had
those words put together or used at all
on this podcast please say that again
turkey serial killers okay thank you go
ahead
and but they were well regarded i mean
if
turkey didn't stand a chance around
these folks and it didn't matter if it
was turkey season or not but they were
well regarded people around the
community you know and
so there was a there was
the
the
crutch of the whole thing was you know
how could people that violated the law
like that be thought of like they were
so it was really interesting
a lot of a lot of good opinions and
you know i still i thought they were
thugs anyway i didn't care so but anyway
there was
that was the the general consensus they
were pretty good folks and and i'm sure
they were but they
to me they're still poachers so so i got
to ask what exactly is bear grease yeah
that's that's because that's
this question it sounds
very inappropriate if that's the word i
want to use or the name of a meth dealer
hey i represent bear grace yeah
bear grease is the render out of if you
take bare fat you take the bare fat off
a bear
and cut it up in cubes put it
in a pot and apply heat to it it will
render down into barrel and bare oil at
one time was a commodity
that was more valuable than anything
else it was traded wren people cook with
it i cook with it
you could light oil lamps with it
where there's a lot of uses for it and
at one time you know it was it was
arkansas was known as the bear state
back when
in that in the middle 1800s
because there were so many bears here
and the
market hunters or whatever came in and
just about extirpated them from the
state because because of how valuable
they were
now they're coming back and
and so the barriers we use electricity
the bear grease podcast
has the documentary part and then we do
every other week we do the bear grease
render so we're kind of rendering down
that
that podcast and
just what we our thoughts and you know
what people think about it real really
popular and a lot of folks a lot of
folks are digging it's a lot of fun
there you go where can everybody find
bear grease at
man you can find it anywhere itunes
spotify it's it's out there it's uh
anywhere you get a podcast you'll you
can get it nice well it was a pleasure
having you we really uh we really
enjoyed having a nice
southern arkansas cop on we
we haven't had any of those so that's a
big plus for us well i appreciate you
guys having me on here you know and
um
the the thin blue line the first
responder line you know it's it's
it is real that that family's real and
yep i mean you guys are my brothers this
is the first time i've seen either one
of you i've listened to your podcast you
got good stuff out there but uh
there's no doubt that you're my family
because the hogs are playing downstairs
in the college world series and i'm
sitting up here talking to you yeah that
is a big deal the sooners are in it too
buddy don't forget
so remember the day
okay
we'll see
all right hey let's go
boom thank you
all right buddy be careful